what's up chickadees I am back on tour
my solo is stopped for now because the
Impractical Jokers are back on our
national tour huge theater Arena tour
it's going on right this second all
tickets are on sale 40 or 50 cities are
on sale we're adding more just go to
impractical
jokerslive.com for all the cities to
take a look uh coming up off the top
right now we have uh Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania Camden New Jersey at the
freedom mortgage Pavilion that's a big
one down Jersey about Philly love to see
you guys two at the Wang in Boston then
we're going to Charleston and Charlotte
and Waterloo New York and then
Washington DC and the big weekend I want
to talk about is Niagara Falls into
Prudential Center in Newark New Jersey
uh then right up to Wallington
Connecticut and coming back down to play
the UBS arena in Long Island those are
all on sale right now plus more and
practicejokerslive.com and Impractical
Jokers season 10 is airing right now on
TruTV and TBS Thursday nights at 10
o'clock folks Joe DeRosa here from the
taste buds podcast I got live
performances and shows and all kinds of
things happening all over the place let
me start with a very special appearance
I'll be making here in New York City on
February 8th at New York City City
Winery my buddy cooge is doing an
evening with cousin friends I'll be
there with couge and some other folks a
little bit of a Roundtable discussion
about food and whatnot lots of laughs
what have you a little bit of a
different show but it's going to be fun
also here in New York City I'm doing my
residency of my new one-man show I Never
Promised You a Rose Garden next one of
those is February 14th the night for
lovers at the crane theater after that
we got one in March on the 22nd again at
the crane theater so if you're in New
York come on by for that and if you're
not New York I'm hitting the big open
road February 18th Vancouver British
Columbia for jfl's Festival Baton Rouge
on March 9th March 10th Lafayette March
11th New Orleans March 30th Amtrak
Michigan March 32 first Grand Rapids
Michigan April 1st Chicago Illinois and
more dates are being added as we speak
all of the dates I just added mentioned
on the road will be me performing the I
Never Promised You a Rose Garden Show
you can go to jodarosainfo.com for
tickets and info also don't forget about
Joey roses open seven days a week at 11
30 a.m every day sandwiches and booze
flowing and chewing all day long
joeyrosesnyc.com taste buds they coming
to the mic talking about the food they
hate talking about the food they like
hey buddies taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds
we're back at it everything's fine
everything is fine what well well the
the last week's oh the heat of the
episode
what about it the heat went out yeah the
heat was on yeah but the heat all right
Glenn Frey oh I was gonna say Robert
Palmer
[Music]
did you ever see that SNL yeah did you
see SNL with Will Ferrell and Ben still
the ages oh yeah yeah that's very funny
um well sometimes people worry that you
know that there's trouble in Paradise
they should know us to know enough to
know that we perform for the show I
gotta tell you too well but but here's
I'll take it a step further than that
yeah sometimes it gets emotional oh for
sure but but here's the thing everything
on the Alps I watched uh uh about but
our job is to argue so like I mean of
course we're gonna argue but also too I
watched about yesterday was Sunday I had
the day off
I cooked and I watched about 27
consecutive episodes of King of Queens
uh I I that's a really funny show I love
it I left it's one of the ones I laugh
out loud people don't talk about it
enough it gets buried under Raymond and
I don't think people talk about Raymond
enough now people talk about Raven still
I I feel like King Queens never got the
just to love it I mean it did well and
it's in reruns but I mean it did you
know but what I was going to say is is
they fight all the time and I was
watching and I was like yeah because
people who love each other fight
sometimes happens correct you know
am I right yeah we should have our own
sitcom we love each other I know well I
do think we should have said I know yeah
yeah I have to do like a new Bosom
Buddies or something
buddy I have such a good idea for a
sitcom really mean the pig to Stefano no
I'm dead serious really yeah let's do it
I am dead serious let's write it off the
cam sitcom I I sketched out the
characters no dead serious when do you
you went that far without mentioning to
me because I did it when we started no
fresh and I did it during when we were
locked down and I had nothing but time
yeah and I mentioned it once to Chris
yeah
and uh coffee's terrible can you put it
up it's disgusting isn't it it's so bad
I mentioned the worst coffee I've ever
had in my life I mentioned it to Chris
once and then I was like you know what
we got a podcast channel to launch let
me focus on that okay
but I got the whole I can tell you the
whole idea right now I'm not going to on
camera but I can at some point I'll tell
you yeah okay
um you know I was watching I actually
watched an episode of King of Queens
last week
um which one was it oh God I was I know
uh uh what's his name Jerry Stiller was
featured prominently because I was
laughing at Jerry Stiller a lot uh
you know there but my point was that I
was because I also watch Raymond because
then that got me thinking oh I love
Raymond Raymond's great so I went and
watched it and for me for my money
Raymond is one of the best sitcoms where
it's not just like paint by like the
fighting is so good the writing is so
far the writing and the acting is so
guided Patricia Heaton is so good
everyone in every single character on
that show is unbelievable and the
writing is they really tap into like
it's so [__] relatable it's my mom's
favorite show of all time yeah she has
said to me many times that the mother
reminds her of her sure and my family
there have been fights on that show that
my family is actually 100 like that they
nail what it's they just nail the truth
of family on that sitcom and then I also
think on King of Queens they do a great
job of nailing the the couple fights
with like because because they are being
unreasonable at times when one is
together or one is being careless or you
know what I like about King of Queens
they never had a kid right
well that's what the whole last season's
about oh it is yeah do they end up
having a kid I don't think
yeah the last season gets
a little heavy have you guys uh have you
guys checked in at all with the other
sitcom they gave Kevin James and the
first season did so poorly they murdered
the wife off and brought back yes Kevin
can wait yes oh it didn't foreign
also wrote on the third sitcom which was
the NASCAR thing which I enjoyed I like
the NASCAR one because on the NASCAR
Netflix sitcom Kevin James was kind of
being like
King of Queens Kevin James again he's
such a good physical comedian yeah and
then like but it was a lot of food I'm a
sucker for a food joke with that guy
okay so he ate there's a scene where
he's complaining he goes I think that
cake we ate at lunch was bad and then uh
cake was bad yeah yeah then later he's
eating it again the lady the sister goes
did you say that cake went bad and he
goes I'm working through it
have you ever thrown something in the
garbage and then five ten half hour one
hour two hours later gone back it's
right at the top and it was a Seinfeld
episode adjacent to refuse is one of my
favorite that's one of my favorite
seinfelds ever yeah yeah it had the
doily on it
the look of the mother when she sees him
bite into it is so horrified
don't let me get this was it in the
trash that would make it
oh my God so funny uh have you done it I
have yeah like if it's in a package if
it's but I've only done it with like I
haven't done it holidays a lot of people
overthrow out a bunch of food like that
wears out that maybe it's a cookie and
it's rusting on top no that I won't do
it garbage no but you don't know what's
in it not the way George did it no no I
the only time I've done it I would have
done what George did if I really wanted
it it was my mind it was mine I'll have
like something in the fridge where I'll
be like like let's say I'm like throw
out Chinese food it's already in the
plastic then you go back take the
plastic bag I maybe finish my own
thought
that we just finished each other's
sentences we're close
uh no but like short of like that but
like sometimes I'll be like uh I'm
starting a food regiment like I'm not
gonna eat cheese because it's just like
a thing I don't need to eat because it's
bad for me and I'll take like a thing of
American cheese and toss it and then
I'll be like that was dumb because this
last this meal I'm making today I could
have just used the last of it and not
waste it and I'll pull it back out
that's the only time I'll do it like I
I've never done it with like I don't
really remember when I've done it I just
know it in my life I've done it and I
would do it if I throw something out and
then have separate thoughts later sure
you know if I I hear you I I think we
need it by the way I just I want us to
do it no matter what happens I love you
today oh sure after after a rough
episode and I can already feel
detention building a little bit now
I didn't feel any tension where did you
get tension from I'm just I'm joking no
you're not I'm half joking it's so that
means you know I just mean because it's
a no no I just mean it's it's such a
we're we're we're we're in the middle of
the 87th Dark Day in New York today I
mean we can't get a Sunbeam in this city
yeah to save our [__] lives right now
it's just we need love right now we need
love and by the way we got LL Cool J
said it best he did I needed Love Oh I
thought you were gonna say I'm bad
I'm bad isn't that Michael Jackson oh
cool Jay forget oreosi Cool J cookies
I'm bad
uh Magnolia Bakery versus coming on next
spot next week and I texted him because
he was into Indian food and I texted him
you know as per us what's your favorite
Indian dish and it's lamb vindaloo so
that's what you're gonna have to be lamb
vindaloo
I I'm not sure of the preparation I've
heard of it but like we'll ask furzie
all right
uh that'd be funny something to tweet
out taste buddies lamb vindaloo
but we could I mean I mean meanwhile
probably the most people on the planet
eat that it's just that we're so
familiar with it we could do lamb versus
something Lamb's a lamb's a very blame
if God takes away the sins of the world
I love lamb I looked into people eating
from
eating to eating something from the
garbage of their life and then 18 admit
to eating on the toilet and in the
bathtub
oh
not in my adult years but I've eaten on
the toilet I feel like I brought my 20s
I probably ate like a piece of pizza or
something sitting on the toilet you know
something like that
I feel like I like when if I was bombed
to something drunk I got a part I don't
know maybe I but I would never read um
in the tub something about that feels so
odd remember that other Seinfeld episode
if it's maybe if it's just nuts or
something that's not that weird or like
I could see having a bubble bath with
some bon bons and some wine oh okay
something like that sure if we're
throwing romance in the mix that gives
it the pass
um Do You Remember That Seinfeld episode
where Kramer just just wants to take a
15 minute nap every like hour or
something like that yeah where he goes
there and we're cutting down my sleep
yeah and he in the shower he has eating
so he takes he makes a salad in the show
yeah yeah yeah the uh I drank I've drank
in the shower
thousand times
your shower is the best thing in the
world yeah yeah yeah that's
if I did that I was in my late teens
early 20s at like a like a beach house
or something like that you know I don't
know if I've done that
by the way speaking of romance love
positivity Beauty food
Ariana from Magnolia Bakery just stop by
stop by to hand deliver us not one but
six
carrot cake cupcakes
which you said was not on their menu yes
they got wind of it and they were like
let me go prove you wrong
that'd be fun if this was the whole
hustle was like you don't have something
so that people bring us yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh the same Magnolia Bakery checks
in the city yeah gramacy Park does not
have a black truffle pasta dish they
don't
uh he said we haven't tried these yet we
said we're gonna eat them on camera yeah
this this put up a red flag for me
though because I know it happens but
this was dead to rights proof that
sometimes you'll say something in an
argument that doesn't have integrity
who made like because you said you said
outright they don't have character in my
defense we immediately Googled it and I
laughed and I go okay I'm wrong right no
no no but if we didn't Google it you
know yeah but but you think you've heard
of everything on Magnolia's menu no I've
just have you ever heard of a carrot
cake cupcake I've never seen one Lord I
would I would bet that they existed I've
never seen one sure I've never but
there's no difference in a cake any cake
there's a cupcake of right I guess so
yeah that's fair that's fair this is my
new shoes but I got a shout out to The
Jeffersons though
sitcom yeah it's my favorite sitcom and
we were talking about that's your of all
time of all time I love The Jeffersons
I'm not knocking yeah I have like a
whole thing like it runs in my childhood
and I when I live with my grandparents
we watched it every night and it just
reminds me of back then and you know and
even now I watch it it's amazing for so
many different reasons I just love it so
much anyway that is a sitcom where they
argued
through every show yo it's about every
show and I think I I don't really
remember back then maybe Archie but like
back then what sitcoms were doing that
but I think that the Jeffersons paved
the way you know for like did you ever
see the other sitcoms have arguing in
the home the arguments between Meathead
and Archie on All in the Family we are
so real and so grounded and like the way
Edith and Gloria react to it like it's
so real like I watched a Brady Bunch
episode today The Honeymooners is
probably the it's probably the first
yeah where it's like the arguments are
you're like holy [__] man that sounds
like a real fight I just you know I just
watched what I just say I just watched I
watch Brady Bunch the same day I was I
guess I don't like TV land or one of
those old school things they argue the
whole time in The Brady Bunch the kids
were fighting the whole time and then it
got Mike and Carol into a fight I never
I always remember this
picture space
I hated The Brady Bunch even as a kid
yeah I liked it but my point being I
also watched an episode of The
Flintstones and I was like I'm gonna
actually watch this and I watched the
whole thing because I think it was
inspired by it yeah yeah yeah and uh man
it was it's crazy it's so adult well it
was meant for adults it was the first
ever Prime Time animated series meant
for adults it was yeah it was it was
meant for the family but it was it was
not a kid this way the the the premise
of the show was that Barney and uh Betty
by the way Betty Rubble nice nice Petty
Rubble I'm trying to think of a
respectful way to say it but it's I I
mean good stuff ready Rubble all day
yeah yeah I know you know what I mean I
know I know I had no idea against Wilma
but Honeymooners Alice all day long yeah
all day long Alice all day long so the
the the idea was that Barney and Betty
couldn't stay home for some reason and
they had to go get a hotel and they were
talking to the Fred and Wilma in their
house and they were like telling them
we're gonna get a hotel they had their
luggage with them and then uh Fred and
Wilma went into the kitchen or the other
room and Fred's like you know I really
feel like we gotta ask them to stay here
you know like it's and it was I guess
and he's like well we're gonna make them
go to a hotel we'll just ask them if
they want to stay here and then they cut
back to Betty and Barney talking and
he's like you see this guy he thinks
he's my friend and he's gonna let us go
to a hotel and not offer us to stay in
his house like that was the whole thing
you know and I'm like wow this is a
cartoon like this is a cartoon content
yeah that's great you know what I mean
that's great that's a groundbreaking
cartoon man who did Fred's voice because
I looked it up recently because I
watched I watched Flintstones Christmas
Carol do they get do they get their do
the people that voiced the yeah if you
look up you know like like for instance
like Fred Welker who's the voice of
Scooby-Doo amongst a million other
things
you know you're not Casey Kasem or
Casey's the voice of screw of Shaggy
friends the dog okay Fred's the dog and
Fred
he's both right right oh yeah what am I
saying he's like he's going to school
but you look up like I I because I own a
lot of
not a lot well decent amount of cartoon
box sets at this point so I always look
up like who did that or whatever and
then like I I find I'm like man this guy
was like this guy's like Pacino and like
the voiceover world you know so that's
why there was all the backlash with the
Super Mario Bros movie that's about to
come out that they recast the voice
actor with Chris Pratt the whole voice
over Community like we're online being
like you took this out like this guy
made your character like he he was Mario
the guy that was like yeah like yeah
they replacing with Chris Pratt
ah and they didn't give it to him but
they need to sell tickets so do you
think that nobody's seen as John Wayne
John Wayne made a great job no one's
going to the yeah but to the movies who
voices them nobody can we eat one of
these
what do you mean I'm dying to try this
oh I mean I feel like it's got to be a
moment though I don't want to do it as
you're talking no let's do it please
unless you still wants I don't know if
you had more to say I'm ready to go babe
now remember I didn't say I didn't like
carrot cake I just said I liked red
velvet better was that what I argued
they both have cream cheese icing it
already it already feels great it's so
soft
maybe I'll eat over the
all right they always went over to box
they always want us to that's disgusting
your food's gonna fall in it
out of your mouth into the box that's
disgusting you of all people I didn't
think we're gonna eat anymore oh I
should bring them home
they should too listen we're gonna eat
what we eat right now like stop putting
limits on things all right why is
everything going to be defined right now
how do you not love this
listen I love Magnolia's approach to a
cupcake is what I love all right all
right Cheers Cheers
no joke very very just so the audio
audience knows there's two grown men
eating over a garbage can no they'll let
us know in the comments no complain
oh my God
my power cake was very good this is
better
as it should be
dude
this is really good God it was like
really good it tastes like what they
would eat like on the Smurfs or
something how so like like some magical
forest Smurf food or something you know
it's gonna win the cook on the Smurfs
like bake something and you're like what
cake it's like is what it's like it's
really good you want one
I'm all right oh shout outs to Magnolia
Bakery wow
top top uh five cupcakes of your life or
not
I mean I don't know this is coming in
heavy right now
I can't recall but there's no way that
this isn't one of the best cupcakes I've
ever had it's doing a thing I made fun
of last week which is but it's working
you can see carrot strips in the cake
is there a crunch DeRosa
there are nuts dude it's every single
thing I argued against this is doing no
actually though what I like though
Magnolia and I think that this was done
on purpose
I like that the nuts are a crumbled
sprinkle on top of the ice cream and not
inside the cake itself
and there's also no big unless I'm not
hitting any there's no raisins which I
also like there's a reason I didn't get
any raisins oh there's one of the best
how's the icing ratio too much icing too
little icing no you always go more which
I like because you can always not eat
all the icing but if you want more icing
and it's not bad that's when you have a
problem and I'll tell you I got one
razor in that final bite
and it was like the Chick-fil-A pickle
it was just perfect it was like that's
it
that is
excellent excellent is it crazy if I ate
another one
no it's only crazy in so much as you
argued against it but not not that you
could eat too much I never say hated
carrot cake oh that's true that is true
oh my God oh my god dude do you want to
split one more
I I would eat the whole [__] box but
I I don't want to eat anymore I I I
wasn't planning on eating that today and
I'm trying to do better for myself gotta
taste one
sprinkle it in a salad he'll eat it I'm
gonna have a beer later yeah
yeah babe just listen to your heart
Roxette said it best
is that Roxette
listen to you when he's calling for you
you've got to look
what in the world can make
will you talk a little bit about our
battle while I eat this other cupcakes
I will
get you too so
um I don't know how it came up but Joe
was
um saying that he'd like to he'd like to
uh to find lasagna
and we were thinking what what could we
go up against lasagna at first we were
thinking like a ravioli because that's
my favorite dish of all time but I
thought we collectively kind of end up
thinking that the ingredients were too
similar and then Pim suggested burrito
which you haven't done before and I love
a burrito and I like lasagna I love all
Italian food but lasagna was never at
the top of my list of Italian foods it's
like if I had to choose five things
before lasagna I could so I'm fine and
burrito is like
it's a it's a it's a it's on a pedestal
a burrito for everybody did you just
lose half that cupcake
I lost a I lost some of the icing that's
a Brand New Bag huh It's a Brand New Bag
go do what we talked about right now
take it back out
do it right now
take the icing out it's very meta
it's a brand new bed It's a Brand New
Bag
yes yes wow you had a chance to make a
moment I can't and good
yes yes yes yes
he's out there eating garbage
God knows who put that bag in yeah we
don't know what was on their hands I
don't know I do want to bring up one
good point soda made about lasagna on an
epic pasta sure it's the best of
casserole world
it's the head that's true
that's true I think
I'm not trying to take credit
but I think actually I said that and I
said after lasagna your casserole World
falls apart
but maybe he did say it maybe he brought
it up I forget who said it but that was
that was his argument that had you dead
to rights in that episode lasagna's
what were you fighting him again salad I
I won didn't Shaolin win
let me let me find it I'm not sure yeah
you had to have won that battle salads
versus casseroles
but you love a casserole
since when
this episode of you on here it's not a
casserole episode but you're you're
defending castles I remember because you
ran out of breath in the middle of it
you bet you're like babe
a lot of casserole babe A lot of
casserole I don't think I would have
said that no I don't like basketball
babe and then you lost your breath
you're like it's casserole I might have
been joking around but I don't love
casseroles I love green bean cat like
the you know that the soup soupy green
bean thing that you get at Christmas
yeah with the mushroom soup and the
green beans or the onion strips yeah
green bean casserole yeah yeah
yeah I could have said that
I love that and I love uh lasagna
God damn it did you throw did you miss
the no I I was throwing the paper away
and a piece of cake fell out of it
that's all right
dude get these away from me
because I'll eat a third one I swear to
God
um
prove it oh God now I feel so guilty
what do you think the calorie count on
one of those things my guess my guess
550.
per
that icing was two inches High pimp give
us a calorie count carrot cake Magnolia
oh you know it's up there why don't you
take a guess before he goes I'm thinking
you're I think you're right in the zone
because you know what I always feel like
45 minimum 45. you pick up a muffin or
carrot cake in like the store and you
look at it I'm always blown away that
it's that high because I'm like is that
only that big remember the time in your
life when because I remember the time of
mine when you thought like a muffin was
like a was a reasonably healthy
breakfast food did he I remember when
like I remember when I was in high
school and I was like I Gotta Lose a
little bit of a weight because I was
like a plant the hockey season was
coming up I remember my friend going
like just eat Bagels
just eat Bagels every day it's just just
bread just eat bagels and I was like
okay and I started eating bagels and
it's like the worst thing that you could
possibly
what do we got
flavor but between 300 and 450 a cupcake
oh even carrot cake though
I can just give me General
they don't have nutrition stats on their
website do people people pull those
stats the second
the FDA was like you don't have to do
that anymore do they not to do it
anymore no no you sure I love that they
did that because I was eating things
that I had no idea like I'd be like I'm
just getting a plate of nachos and it's
like 3 500 calories in one plate of
nachos yeah as a matter of fact it makes
me make healthier choices because they
still I still see it on menus and when I
go I look and I go oh my God I can't
have one dish that's 1800 calories
that's crazy even a dish that's 1400 I
know I'm like let me just look for the
the least thing the least offensive
thing I gotta tell you it does help I
got to tell you and this this is this is
right on the money what we're talking
about you know we have a sink here
I know but I didn't want to have to
leave the room you're washing your hands
like you're a homeless person at Grand
Central Station well I ate out of the
trash I'll bathe in it
the uh
uh yesterday
from Saturday night at like 9 00 PM
until yesterday afternoon I had a
craving for McDonald's that was going so
out of control and I'm trying I'm like
I'm fighting it I'm fighting it I'm
trying not to do it I'm trying not to do
it to fight it I'm supposed to be on a
diet which is now I'm sad that I ate two
cupcakes but they were so good uh but uh
and I'm fighting it I'm fighting I'm
fighting it
so I attempted yesterday
to make health make Health Donald's at
home oh I love it dude I love it so
you're so you're gonna make a
cheeseburger and a fry as
and you're gonna attempt to make it as
close to their taste as possible Big Mac
fries nuggets
that was my attempt Nothing's Gonna
taste that's the whole point you can
never match that taste I know but I
tried yeah okay babe Bessie became a
sponsor of our show yes I got asked to
pick shoes out yeah pick the size 11
these black low top shoes now the thing
with them are they're they're
comfortable as heck they are both on the
foot and like you could stand in them
for hours and I say this every time I do
a vessel because people know that I am a
shoe person and a sneaker head and I put
these vessels on it's the first time I
ever tried them or heard about them and
they were as comfortable or if not more
than my most comfortable they're
ridiculously comfortable but here's why
that's even more relevant not the fact
that you want shoes to be comfortable
they're waterproof 100 waterproof not
water resistant yeah yeah and it's and
it's it's this patented like actual like
material that's like it's breathable
cloth material dime attacks which is fun
to say diamond Texas so I got I got a
pair for me me and my dad are the same
size I gave them to my dad he put him on
and he was like this is
he looked at me and he was like this is
crazy I tried them on I was like oh my
God like I wasn't expecting I wouldn't
have gave them to you yeah and then I
went back and I bought a new a pair of
the new storm burst uh they sent I got
and there's have you tried the stormers
uh this web this New York right now this
New York weather storm burst all the way
dude oh wait it's awesome yeah that
might be what I came up like a high top
yeah I had to have big rubber down here
and yeah huge the traction at the bottom
I have a Chelsea boot yeah kind of thing
right yes like The Styling and it ties
up almost like a mine just slip right in
I slip right you don't have laces on
yours I slipped oh I have laces on mine
I love it I do a slip yeah you could
walk like the traction's ridiculous
there's no sliding but I walk through
puddles like what now puddle yeah yeah
yeah no it's amazing now if shoes this
comfortable the feel like sneakers that
are completely waterproof that you can
wear in any type of weather in in any
state you're living in as a game changer
uh but but anyway the lighter and more
comfortable if you're in an inner city
thing it's just it's just unbelievable
yeah they're lighter more comfortable
than boots it's like wearing a winter
boot that's a sneaker that really is
what it's like uh they have a let me
just read this podcast I thought this
was important they have a lugged rubber
outsole
that gives you extra grip in wet
conditions which I said is added lining
inside for the extra warmth in the
winter because you would look at them
and not think that you're going to be
warm because they're thin so they're
light but then then all of a sudden
they're freaking really warm excuse my
language read that next read that they
slip on and off it's quick and easy to
get outside slip on it oh yeah it's not
mine okay all right listen go get a pair
of your own uh vessels are my go-to
shoes by my door check them out on the
link vesi.com taste buds for a pair of
your vessi shoes and you're gonna get 15
off your entire order
vesi.com
v-e-s-s-i.com taste buds guys this new
year you've got goals and factors here
to help you achieve each and every one
of them save time and have the energy
you need to tackle everything on your
to-do list with factors ready to eat
meals delivered straight to your door
get factor and not only skip the trip to
the grocery store but skip the chopping
the prepping and the cleaning up to
factors fresh never frozen meals already
in just two minutes so all you have to
do is heat up and enjoy no matter what
your lifestyle is Factor has the meals
to help you live life to the fullest
they have keto calorie smart vegan and
veggie options Protein Plus meals uh are
on the menus every single week they're
prepared by chefs and approved by
dietitians each meal has a lot of
ingredients you need to feel satisfied
all day long with 34 Chef prepared
dietitian approved weekly options
there's always something new to try
looking to cut back on a takeout get
Factor instead not only is it cheaper
than takeout but the meals already
quicker that's why I want to do it is to
to sit
in those moments where you're like I'll
just get take out yeah you know it's
that I well I like you know he's back
tired or whatever it is I get Factory
delivered every Wednesday I have it on
six meals and I get also six strawberry
banana smoothies they're really low in
sugar it's like I use them for breakfast
and the meals
are great and this they're really really
filling I freaking love it if I get that
if I'm like oh I'm hungry dude I'm
eating it's no joke it is exactly two
minutes and you're literally eating it
and they have so many different dishes
you can go on every week and you can get
the same thing you can let them choose
or you could just go unselect stuff and
select the stuff you want it comes like
in a uh in just uh with dry ice in a box
but it's not frozen it's fresh yeah
throw it right in the fridge it's good
for a whole week it's sealed I love it
it's actually been helping me lose
weight it's great because every meal
like is like between 500 and 600
calories and it fills you up so you
can't go wrong I love this enjoy clean
eating without the hassle which is nice
uh and I also add to that enjoy clean
eating without all the cleanup yeah you
just throw that thing right out yeah
also if you're trying to become a vegan
or a vegetarian or you are one and you
wanna another option they have that for
you and that that's something that
in any day and age when I was a
vegetarian for seven years when I was in
my teens there was no there was no way
to easily get a vegetarian never mind
vegan no I know I I it's tough out here
for a vegan in the streets now that's
the factof75.com go ahead Joe head to
factor75.com tastebuds60 use promo code
taste buds 6-0 and get 60 that's six
zero percent off your first box that's
code taste buds 6-0 at factor75.com
tastebuds60 to get 60 off your first box
we'll do the we'll do the battle right
after this but let me walk you through
it
and I know I say all the time you can't
match the flavor but I'm like if I get
it close enough it'll just sate the
craving sure but what's funny is yours
are probably yours is going to taste
better than theirs but it's not it
doesn't tasty it didn't
wait wait do you hear what I did
so I start by going to McDonald's
and going out to the register can I have
the bottom how many sausages can I get
for 10 bucks and the guy's like what do
you mean I go I need the McNugget sauces
and he goes I'll just give them to you
and I go no no I'll pay for him he goes
no no just take him I go should I want
some hot mustards and barbecues because
I was like that's the one thing that I
will not be able to do in any way right
that's I was like if I get the sauces
like the rest of this will be cream
cheese because then the sauce sure you
know half the battle that's GI Joe would
say so I do that then I go and I get
Beyond chicken nuggets vegetarian
chicken nuggets interesting why would
you do that if you're trying to recreate
because the because the whole problem
was I was like I was like I don't want
to eat
like all the [__] in it and everything I
was like I just don't wanna it was like
the the saturated fat all this stuff
right
so I just was like and that's like
probably so many and whatever I just was
like I just didn't feel good about it so
I go and I get Beyond chicken nuggets
and then I go and I get sweet potato
fries instead of regular fries what are
you doing I know it was a mistake and
then I get a thing of impossible burgers
together
see you didn't buy me the chicken right
because I keep thinking
right you're not trying to recreate
anything don't lie to yourself I promise
you I was I thought this was going to
work so I get impossible Burger a pack
of two pack of impossible burgers
I buy Ken's sorry not Ken's sir
Kennington uh sir kensington's babe Mr
Kensington they sell a thing called
Special Sauce I know about fry sauce
it's just called special sauce and it's
for it's like the sauce for burgers oh
yeah orange stuff yeah I know the
Thousand Island dressing whatever so I
buy that because I'm like that'll be the
healthiest version of long island of
thousand island dressing yeah
I buy a head of iceberg lettuce
onion I go home oh and then for the bun
I bought you should ask for a bun at
McDonald's
I I was trying to eat a healthy bun so I
went and got I was trying to make
healthy McDonald's okay all right so I
went to Trader Joe's and I got these
multi-grain like fins that like earlier
you're not making healthy McDonald's at
this point you're just making you're not
even making a cheeseburger wait for this
ready ready
wait for this wait for it wait for it
so I'm home I start making it I shred
the lettuce I chop the onion I slice
pickle and this whole time you're hoping
that what this results in will take away
your craving yeah okay it'll be a and
I'll be like I found a healthy version
to make that because I will say Beyond
chicken fingers
I can't tell that they're not chicken
they're unbelievable but they didn't
have those shut up they only had shout
outs they only had the nuggets and they
were good the Nuggets weren't bad
but dude Beyond people if you're
watching and we know that you are send
us a bunch of Beyond products please
yeah uh so dude I as I'm cooking this
I'm so proud of myself I get the sweet
potato fries baking whatever I look up
the calorie by the way I did my Big Mac
without cheese to save on calories okay
I do the calorie count of my Big Mac
versus the real Big Mac mine is more no
how's that possible
it just was yours is healthier for sure
yes it was more calories but I'm sure
that my body got a little
in theory something more out of it it
definitely got more fiber like more
productive fiber out of it whatever I
know there's a million people watching
right now that want to start writing in
about how the only healthy diet is in
all cheese and spare ribbed I hit that
you heard about on Rogan
or whatever I know guys my point is is
I was trying to do something that I
thought would be a healthy alternative
less saturated fat whatever
and in those senses it did there was a
lot there was a lower sodium count and
all that stuff so in theory it was
healthier
but I gotta tell you dude outside of the
Beyond nuggets
it [__] sucks well there wasn't a
whole there wasn't a single matching
ingredient how are you going to make
something taste like that well I thought
because in a Big Mac I'm like what are
you tasting primarily you're tasting
that sauce with the bun and everything
do they still chop up the onions
McDonald's yeah that's a fun thing I put
it in a blender and made diced onions I
shredded the lettuce
I did I did everything by the book dude
and like I like impossible you just
didn't you think they blend their onions
or chop them
well they nobody's chopping them there I
know that I have a little countertop I
love those like electric chopper blender
things you throw an onion in and and
like a magical ten seconds it's
literally chopped like McDonald's now
but um
I thought that like
I like impossible Burgers I like sweet
potato fries and I love Beyond nuggets
and the Beyond nuggets with the sauce I
gotta admit like I'm like I could live
with this I really could like this this
would get the McNugget craving out of my
system but it was just all overpowered
by the disappointment of like the
lettuce had too much water in it and it
made the burger wet and the The
Impossible patties
to think that you could go to the store
and buy impossible meats and come back
and make yourself something that would
be akin to their taste their taste is
one of a kind nobody can greet the taste
that's the whole problem that's the
whole that's their whole that's what
their business is based on you don't
have to tell me you can't recreate that
taste what do you think but as you
addicted to this restaurant
because it's the best tasting food
that's ever existed do you feel that way
I'd be hard-pressed to argue against it
I mean food that makes us come back as
an MSG
I don't know this is what I'm trying to
tell you you would think you
if I told you the recipes of a big the
recipe of a Big Mac
that
I and again I have argued at length you
cannot recreate the flavor of McDonald's
that's what makes it so special Wendy's
to me is great but you could you could
in theory recreate it but you would
still think
if I was home and I took the ingredients
of a Big Mac that I bought elsewhere and
put them together
it would taste
I would get pops of those flavors enough
that I'd be like okay I don't need to
have a Big Mac now I am back to square
one that's how far off it was I don't
it's everything Paul spent 100 years
mastering this I'm telling you dude it's
the texture it's the fact that you could
you could literally chew it without
teeth which you've made fun of me for
saying
as a plus it's have you ever worked at
McDonald's no I'm surprised how did that
how did that not call you when you were
younger uh it didn't look like a fun job
to me but my buddy Dan worked there when
he was in high school and he said it was
the most fun job he ever had really he
said it was a blast which I you know I
guess it could be it kind of looks like
that I'm having like a free [__] an
American what's that movie called
American Dreams what the [__] that
movie with Kevin Spacey where he [__]
Beauty American Beauty I kind of have
that now when I go in and I'm like that
looks like kind of that looks fun and
I'm like oh I'm like Kevin Spacey
American Beauty age yeah would you ever
work a guest shift as a punishment
a thousand percent
you make that happen you think so yeah
because it looks like I don't know I
don't know what the season two stats are
but dude
what McDonald's is gonna let me do that
they're not gonna let me do that they'll
let you do it all right yeah we know
some franchisee owners yeah yeah I want
in with McDonald's 1
000 I can't stress that enough really
pimp I I kicked around starting a
McDonald's podcast oh wow
I kicked around starting McDonald's
podcast what would it be here's what's
crazy I was saying to my social media
guy the other day
I said dude if I did that
like I go I think there are people out
there that would do that because they'd
be like oh it'll get hits because you
have McDonald's at the time I go dude
that would just be a perk for me I
literally could start a McDonald's
podcast and talk about McDonald's like
like genuinely yeah but that well is
going to run dry now
I don't know I don't know I don't know
by the way season two it says here Joe
uh won 20 battles Sal 125.
okay and there's nine left
uh no they're already on season three
here in our no pressure
what am I saying we're past episode 104.
we're gonna win this battle today you
ready so you lost season two so there's
another punishment coming your way oh I
didn't lose season two yet it says we're
in season three boom season three what
52 52 to a season
ish come on man you lost my all right
I'll tell you what I'll tell you what
let's combine the punishments I'll wear
the McDonald's costume as I work a
McDonald's shift that is so much better
than me bartending at Joey Rose's in the
thing I don't know if it is but we'd
have to now I'd have to I mean that's we
might have to get signed off on that
yeah we stole that yeah allegedly all
right fine then that's my season two
punishment I'll work it I'll work let's
define shift an hour or two I'm not
doing an eight-hour shift
I was gonna say four you have to do
enough to be able to work every station
like you can't I will I will do that I
actually would be excited to do that it
might be fun not much of a punishment we
should film those soon because I have
just a full Ronald McDonald outfit in my
house yeah I know well well Sal's Sal's
free-ish again so let's can we close
that for a little bit yeah I know it got
so cool we got to get to this battle
dude okay here we go where are we at
pimp we're deep into it like 30
something
all right yeah all right keep it tight
yeah
don't be shitty no all right yeah don't
be shitty
all right yes
you were doing I love you sure I feel
like it's too nice today already now I
want to do a a a a well you're all over
the place now all right let's do it I
love you all right
no matter what happens this is your
commitment
get your head in the game get your head
in the game come on man no no you just
one-handed is fine but just like you
mean it yeah
no matter what happens I love you no
matter what happens I love you no matter
what happens I love you time for
b-a-t-t-l-e boots all right lasagna
versus burrito I am team lasagna Salas
team burrito here we go and I will start
by saying these are two items that most
of the time always contain the same
ingredients my item is better why
because my item in my opinion is an
event item you're gonna make lasagna you
were that is a day of your life you're
telling people I'm making lasagna here
we go you're inviting people over I'm
gonna make lasagna people are saying
we're excited Terry's making lasagna on
Sunday we're all going over for dinner
you get a plate of lasagna put down in
front of you you scoop it under the pan
you get the string cheese going
it's just an event food it's just an
absolute event food and I I love a
burrito I really
to an extent
uh I always get my burritos no rice
can't stand rice in a burrito and uh and
my to an extent comes from the fact that
a burrito has a real real short shelf
life man that's it's it's like if you
don't get into that thing right away
it does not come together internally in
a way that you want to eat eight hours
later after it's set I would disagree on
that statement I love that you can get a
burrito and it feels like five five
pounds of burrito you know what I mean
like it's it's it's the typical burrito
by the way is this is this Americanized
Mexican this is Tex-Mex really right
right like I don't think they have I
don't think burritos I mean I know
burritos like Mexican food but like I'm
saying I don't think a burrito is a
traditional Mexican so I don't think I
might be wrong right but what we have
here so first of all I I I I disagree
with you additional staple of their oh
okay yeah but it feels like such an
Americanized yeah do you want to know
what the name means
sure the name is originally means donkey
little donkeys what a burrito means
well it's probably the weight of a
little donkey so what's lasagna mean uh
name of the dish
that's just it yeah okay
lasagna means the dish so they named it
after the dish
oh the dish it's baked in is called a
lasagna
what the [__] I guess that's Italian for
casserole
the word lasagni did not refer to the
food it referred to the pot in which the
food was cooked wild never knew that
well that's a casserole that's a that's
a it's a hip name for a pot
well
lasagna yes casserole Probably sounds
exotic in Italy too so you could be
eating a cast you could so they lasagna
but so but you can cook other it's made
in a casserole dish so you can cook
other things in a lasagna I think this
would be something to do with a Greek
word meaning chamber pot I think it's
like an old school dish sure you're
getting pulled from it's getting pulled
from a Greek word that's odd well maybe
it's a Greek dish originally rocket
money formerly known as true bill is
here to help you what those
sign up for things whether it's a
streaming service or some kind of
recurring uh Subscription Service
whatever it is and you forget you forget
you forget and in your head when you
know you're gonna forget you say well
what's 5.99 I'm looking at you Apple
games what's 9.99 well it adds up folks
and that's why rocket money was created
that's what they're there to do to or
that's how they're here to help is to
help you locate these things find these
subscriptions let you know what you're
spending every month and let you cancel
the things you don't want to do anymore
how great is that you could look at all
your subscriptions at a glance and
cancel them at the same place with a
touch of a button yeah you press cancel
that's it yeah you're done all within
the app stop throwing your money away
cancel those unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses uh how the easy way
quite frankly go to rocketmoney.com
tastebuds that's rocketmoney.com
tastebuds rocketmoney.com
com slash taste buds oh here's the thing
I don't disagree that like a lasagna
could be like oh it's a tradition it's a
Sunday thing lasagna is like you know
but when I'm thinking of Italian foods
there are so many variations just like
with Mexican food just like with Chinese
food Italian food has a lot of
variations of the same type of thing all
the types of different pastas are made
some mostly the same but they're
different shapes because different
shapes are better for what they're for
what they're right lending to that to
that bite right so with lasagna for me
you know you got meat you got cheese you
got sauce you got pasta I have that in a
lot of other Italian dishes and lasagna
is not at the top of that list my
favorite food of all time is a Ravioli
and anything that's in a lasagna can
almost be in a ravioli in a bite-sized
version of it which I love that's a that
is an absolutely incorrect statement
what you just said what do you mean
lasagna hold on lasagna features
multiple cheeses
right it's layered and sauce is
contained within it I understand the
concept but I'm saying I'm saying the
ingredients you could not put you could
not put multiple you could not put all
three if you stuck to just the meats of
the two cheeses it wouldn't work inside
a ravioli why because because the the
the
um uh the uh mozzarella cheese would
melt differently inside the revenue I I
understand the layers and the ravioli
would fall apart it just wouldn't
not speculating about how what the
ravioli would do I could tell you
ravioli wouldn't do that if you make the
ravioli correctly no you can't pack all
that inside a ravioli it doesn't work
you mean to tell me that if Gordon
Ramsay is right here and I asked him to
do that he wouldn't be able to do it
you're gonna tell me you're gonna boil
because raviolis are boiled yeah you're
gonna boil a ravioli with Regatta meat
and was and shredded um uh mozzarella
inside that's been done I maybe deep fry
it maybe it's deep fried it yeah I'm
sure there whether the ravioli can
recreate it my point is is that if I'm
thinking of my all-time favorite Italian
dishes eggplant parm chicken parm
ravioli linguine clams like things like
that I got five dishes coming in before
lasagna easy if not more you're nuts
lasagna is good but it's
it's
people don't eat lasagna all the time
for a reason you can't people don't eat
linguine with clams all the time for no
reason people don't eat raviolis all the
time people eat burritos all the time oh
burrito is a go-to food no matter who
you are I don't think they don't
understand the ages burrito high school
kid college kids pound them adults pound
them little kids I don't think that's
fair to say that people eat them all the
time I think I think if lasagna was more
readily available people would eat it
more frequently I don't think it's you
know there's not lasagna stands on the
street of course because it takes more
commitment a burrito let's be honest no
offense to the good people of Mexico uh
or their fine cuisine which I love I'm
gonna make a taco kit tonight all right
but let's be honest the burrito ain't no
rocket science man you got three tins of
some stuff and you throw it together you
roll it up and then you you call it a
day you make lasagna takes a hell of a
lot more you're making you're selling it
short you're making it look like it's
very easy when a good burrito done the
right way is not that easy okay but I'll
tell you what the burrito in a year in a
calendar year what do you think you have
a more burrito or lasagna
burrito but because of accessibility
okay so that's a plus right
no not necessarily it just did it's look
I have potato chips more than I have
burritos it doesn't mean that I think
potato chips have a one-up on burritos
for that reason accessibility is is is
is besides the point to me but I will go
back to a point you just made and and
harshly disagree I can promise you right
now if you took somebody who didn't know
how to cook or didn't know their way
around the kitchen and you presented
them with the ingredients needed to put
a burrito together or the ingredients
needed to make a lasagna that burrito
was going to taste way better than their
lasagna is gone I don't know what what
that has to do with I don't know how
that supports either I'm saying you can
throw a burrito together more easily
it's more accessible
and that but that's why it's more
accessible all right you can't you can't
fault something that's accessibility
because it's a much more complicated
thing to put I would liken the burrito
to what you just spoke about with the
Big Mac or McDonald's to you people all
of a sudden have a hankering and get in
the mood for a burrito people like oh my
God it's almost like sushi in that way
where you're like oh let's go get
burritos you know what I mean like
burritos are like something that people
come back around to that they crave that
they're excited they're not eating it
all the time but they're very excited
when they're gonna go get a burrito I
don't think people are like oh my god
let's get lasagna lasagna you're nuts
you're not when you find a place that
has good lasagna you will talk about it
you you'll be like do you ever have the
lasagna and such and such burritos
you're like but hey as a burrito there
it's good the lasagna that's good the
lasagna does not accomplish what the
burrito accomplishes to the masses
whether it's accessibility or not people
are like oh let's get a [__] burrito
like I'm in the mood for a burrito you
know what I mean oh I had a burrito I I
can't I don't I don't I never hear
people be like Oh I'm in the mood for
lasagna oh let's go get lasagna tonight
I don't really do it I'm rare I'm just
speaking personally I'm rarely in the
mood for a burrito I'm in the mood for
tacos almost all the time uh whether
they're traditional Mexican style tacos
or like the Tex-Mex a lot of the same
ingredients kit or whatever no no
tacos are much simpler more streamlined
thing what do you mean you got you got a
burrito could have anything it could
have blackened chicken it could have
pork I'm sure but it's but that's versus
if you want to talk okay but but Taco
sour cream shredded cheese lettuce
tomato
I don't use sour cream I don't use
lettuce but but that's besides the point
that's a Tex-Mex style taco if you want
to talk traditional tacos versus the
burrito which pimp has pointed out as a
traditional American food or Mexican
food a taco in Mexico a traditional
Mexican taco is a tiny corn tortilla
meat sometimes onions and cilantro and
then some salsa a burrito is a flour
tortilla Which in my opinion is
substandard by far to the corn tortilla
then it's got rice beans meat guac I
love it sour cream pico de gallo and
somehow they all come together isn't
that insane wow they all come together
for a taste explosion sure I love that
it's like it's too much it weighs like a
it's like a it's like a newborn baby
it's like a it's like five pounds I mean
you want to talk wait I like lasagna
around half of it wrapping it up putting
the other one the other half in the
fridge and you say you can't re-eat
burrito I say a burrito is kind of
almost made for that no dude no it's
grocery you've got the beauty of the
burrito on the grill and get it nice and
blackened and toasted the beauty of a
burrito is you've got cold meeting hot
inside this magical you know thing
that's wrapped it all up together
whatever
I'm you I'm I'm saying magical
differently than you are I'm saying just
like you know from a tech from a
technology standpoint they've designed
this whatever you use this magical it
means it's positive uh but you know it's
an edible piece of paper basically that
they're wrapping all this stuff up
inside of
um
the the the the beauty of that when it's
done right is the heart clashing with
the cool
the second you let that thing sit
the deterioration begins when you pull
that out of the fridge later
and Sal you know this is true that
[__] flower thing has become hard in
places and and damp and and mushy and
others the the lettuce and all that [__]
has wilted because it's been sitting
next to the hot stuff for too long
the the guac and sour cream have fused
into some inexplicable new paste uh it's
just gross dude and then when you reheat
it now you got hot lettuce
it's gross I like to say though I don't
know what that has how that can be
applied to this argument your arguing
you said you like you were eating it
later and I'm saying you said you can I
say I do I say it has no use but but but
but its ability to be eaten later has
nothing to do with what we're focusing
I'm just saying because you've just
mentioned it I'm speaking to it sure
lasagna on the other hand well no you
mentioned it but I do think but I do
think that that that's a credit to it I
do think there's something to be said to
the construction of a food if it has a
little come on we argue that all the
time on this podcast you you you
especially always argue you'll be like
dude the second that hits the table the
countdown begins it's gonna suck in 10
minutes it's gonna suck in 20 minutes
I'm saying that about the burrito I'm
saying you got a window where you got to
eat that thing and and by the way if
they constructed it properly with
portions proportionally a burrito needs
to be put together the right way lasagna
on the other hand
dude you're reheating that [__] for days
for days and every time it's coming back
out of the onion out of the oven as a
banger as a banger dude like it's just
the wealth uh that you get from lasagna
the worth of it the longevity that
that's I mean you're feeding the you're
talking about the weight of a burrito
carry a dish of lasagna you feel like
you're you're moving a dead body it's
heavy as [__] who can't like to lasagna
here
okay Garfield all right Garfield
um yeah another thing um
I disagree with what you said about
burrito and lasagna making and I'll tell
you why I'm Italian I love I do like
lasagna I don't not like it right but
it's not at my top of my Italian dishes
but I will tell you this and this is
true from my life let's say the last 20
lasagnas I've had I bet you like five
were good like there's so many not no no
don't come in with this don't come in
with this right now I'm gonna I'm gonna
latch on to what you said it's not easy
to make and a lot of times it could be
watery a lot of times there's too much
pasta the cheese comes out the sides
it's not built the right way it's not
layered the right way it's not
proportioned the right way I've had
plenty of bad lasagnas
good lasagnas but I just mean like I
think more so than not one of the
reasons because I'm thinking why why
don't I have lasagna at the top of that
list and again
I just think it's because most of the
time a lasagna doesn't blow me away I'm
not saying that a lot lasagna can't and
there's not good lasagna but a lot of
times if you're where are you having
lasagna you know if you're not making it
at home where are you having it Italian
restaurant
do you order it then
you have an old lasagna at a time I
really don't but I have yeah yeah I mean
I've had it from a pizza place okay
restaurant you know well I mean yeah I
mean okay everything else there's a
lasagna Pizza hell of a lot better than
a burrito Pizza no I have not promise
you very good I I don't know man it's
just a lot of times like the cheese the
meat and everything is a little bit off
and then when you when here's another
thing I don't like about lasagna okay
you go to cut it
with your fork and it's nearly like
sometimes everything shoots out at the
bot in the middle of it you go to cut it
and one of those sheets is loose and all
of a sudden all the stuff just shoots
out and it's hard to get a perfect nice
bite square with everything compact
together if you thought of using a knife
to perhaps cut your food instead of just
using a fork I could use a knife I mean
your whole argument is built for your
food and against mine is built around
laziness I want my food rolled up in a
piece of edible paper uh so I don't have
to think slop it all together in there
for me and when I eat your food I only I
demand I use one utensil to eat how many
times you eat a lasagna that's a perfect
square almost like a slice of cake and
through the whole thing you eat it stays
like that a lot of times people take
that lasagna off the pan drop it in your
plate and the whole thing sinks like two
inches and everything comes out the
sides and then you're just kind of
scooping it up and eating it like soup I
don't know this comes out the sides
business I I understand what you're
saying if you apply pressure to
something that has layers some stuff
right that's perfect the course that
doesn't bother me due to lasagna but is
it no correct me if I'm wrong isn't the
experience of eating lasagna the fact
that it's layered that way in that style
and that that attributes all of its
that's what it's all about right
otherwise it would just be any other
Italian Dish it's you eat it in that way
and that texture and that sequence we
can go tit for Ted here how many times
you eat a burrito you bite into it and
cream is shooting out of it or guacamole
is shooting out of it or or the lettuce
and the rice are falling out of it or
the Pico's falling out of it or the
ground beef is falling out of it
burritos but it's a hand food it's a
hand food in theory you would never
all right well yeah I mean maybe you
would but I can tell you this when I eat
a burrito I am not walking freely and
eating a burrito I am not sitting lazily
on the couch anymore I am over a [__]
dish with it because [__] is falling out
of it the entire time and I don't want
to get
if you want to spill stuff on your shirt
you can
see how lazy are you you're walking and
eating a burrito isn't that not lazy
wouldn't be sitting how much
multitasking do you need to do with your
food sit and eat your food I don't
understand you think that walking while
holding a burrito is multitasking I find
I find walking and eating to be an issue
good luck trying to walk with the
lasagna well I would never would I
38 years old I made a hard rule for
myself no more walking while you eat you
sitting you could take a burrito in a in
a foil and unwrap it and eat it any way
you want it's almost like a [__]
banana and you'll spill it on your pants
or shirt I promise not if you have motor
skills no that's not true Sal put
yourself that's not true that's not true
I'm just saying no food you know
versatile yes
you're not only in the mobility of it
but you could have beef steak chicken
pork you could have vegetarian burrito
put any of that in vegetarian lasagna
beef lasagna pork lasagna pork Bring It
On yeah ground pork why couldn't you do
that have you I haven't but I would but
you haven't try and stop me and you've
been alive a long time I've seen chicken
uh lasagna oh Joe what do you mean oh
Joe now this is getting gross why is it
gross you eating a chicken lasagna
chicken parm chicken goes in red sauce
all the time that's what I just said
though I said that you can get any of
those ingredients in another dish so why
do I need them I also think it's very I
can get any of your ingredients
very pasta heavy those pasta sheets
sometimes are way too much it's a pasta
dish you [__] it's too much though the
proportions don't always come together
the way I would like them to oh God
there's a great fan tweet lasagna is the
drunk drunk junk draw of Italian foods
oh oh I don't know if I agree with that
but it isn't at the top of my list any
any negative burrito comments
that is that's true that is and the
burrito's like a warm hug from your
Mexican grandmother
look here's the thing if my Mexican
grandmother made me a burrito I thought
I'd go take a walk I'd say sit down and
focus on this [__] meal lady and put
some [__] together in a dish right I had
to eliminate one okay I'm Italian
enchiladas would be a Mexican
grandmother nice thing a burrito I'd be
like lady get your [__] together I'm
Italian uh half and I love Italian food
is my favorite food and if I had to
choose one to be eliminated for good and
keep one I would choose the burrito over
lasagna because I can get all I can get
the taste of a lasagna and so many other
foods I can get the taste of a burrito
and so many other Foods I agree but
but the burrito is just more it's there
for you you have it more you need it
more you want it more you don't crave it
more you don't need it more you don't
crave it one if I say to people do you
create what do you crave more from time
to time a burrito or lasagna even people
that like both dishes You're Gonna Hear
burritos I gotta tell you one to one I
love Mexican food I love Tex-Mex food I
love both versions of Mexican food I
crave nachos I crave enchiladas I crave
tacos burrito is so far down the list of
the things
but let me say why let me say why is so
far down the list of things I crave in
that genre of food because I'm like it
steps in and it takes over the entire
meal and you feel sick or unsatisfied
there's no perfect balance with a
burrito there's no there's no if I eat
lasagna is heavy as [__] let me flip I'm
just telling you something if I eat half
I don't feel full if I eat the whole
thing I'm too full
you can control it also takes away the
joy of the of the flavors of the things
because it's all just slopped together
and not showing what you're saying now
is not just for instance saying that
multiple ingredients together is a slop
versus multiple ingredients that is a
meal and a dish I'll tell you why I'll
tell you why let's take nachos for
instance which has almost all of the
same exact ingredients minus the rice of
a burrito with nachos you take a chip
from over here you get some cheese and
Chip you go over here you get some
cheese and jalapeno and meat you go over
here you take this one you dip it into
the guac you dip this one in the sour
cream you have a control they say nachos
you have a control I'm telling you why
the burrito sucks or or not sucks but
isn't it it's good one of the reasons
you just said a burrito is not good is
because
if you eat too little you're not full
and if you eat too much you get full yep
I mean you can apply that to anything
but you know what I mean well okay
often after a burrito I can control that
just don't overeat I'd rather get a
couple other things off of a off of a
mix of a Mexican Restaurant's menu and
enjoy a separation of flavors and not
have to face that challenge versus pasta
and meat I think is as heavy with
anything anything in the burrito what do
you get in a flour tortilla and some
rice beans and that's it the rest of
it's I'll tell you the difference for
whatever reason when you get lasagna
you get a little you get a cut portion
like you said it's like cake
that portion works it works for whatever
reason for me usually the size that they
give you at a restaurant is is akin to
the size I get at home or whatever that
I would cut for myself at home or that
my mom would come for me it's it's it
works a burrito's portion is off again
if you eat the whole thing you don't
feel good and if you don't eat the whole
thing you feel sort of unsatisfied so
all I'm going to say to that is just eat
the right amount for yourself so okay so
and then throw the other half away
because that because it doesn't keep
well all right it's that's the strike
again I tend to think everything wrapped
up in that tortilla is fun burrito is a
fun food lasagna is a sit down make sure
you don't get any sauce on your shirt
eat it with a cold type food you got it
you live in the mobility I love it I
love that everything's getting around as
a matter of fact when a burritos being
made I love watching them rapid
some sack of stone sitting here right
now talking about worrying about what
gets on your shirt with lasagna and not
a burrito you're out of your you're out
of your [__] mind right now sauce
though sauce splashes
splashes what are you doing throwing
things into oh God forbid a piece drops
back in the in the plate that so red
sauce is going on what do you think uh
guac does what do you think hot sauce
doesn't Splash like that what do you
think sour cream does it doesn't Splash
like that what about what about hot
sauce on a burrito what does that do
is like that
I actually love the fact that all that
stuff is you're carrying it in one
pocket you've made it very clear that
you like to carry food
I could take a burrito with me into a
movie theater I love that I do I love
that I could a burrito can go in my
jacket pocket I could take it anywhere I
want to go it's like in your American
Express he says it's everywhere you want
to be in his jacket pocket how could you
fit it in your jacket pocket it's so
enormous and huge it's like a baby I
think you you it's about five pounds
made it Akin too did you not I'll give
it to my jackpot I've done it all right
that's capital lasagna that's gross
that's really gross that you're putting
food into your pockets I'm sorry it's
just weird it's just gross uh I will
agree with you loose
it's just weird no it's not it's weird
you never put a wrapped sandwich from a
deli in your pocket as you walked no one
took a sandwich from your own [__]
establishment that was wrapped no put in
your jacket pocket as you went home no I
say give me a bag that's what we have
those for it I carry it like a human
being and here's the weird I like my
hand here's the real weird I like my
hands down here's the real world part I
don't eat it on the walk home I wait
till I'm home and I sit down and chill
if you head at home and I eat it I'm not
saying I eat burritos I warm the wok I'm
saying you can and that's a plus not a
negative you can't turn that into a
negative so you could eat it doing more
things than you what's what is the
negative what's the negative that if you
eat a burrito walking you're saying
you're gonna get rice on you
I just think it's a it it's not I'm not
saying it's a negative I think it's
weird to say that it's an attribute of
the food that's what's weird to me it's
a weird thing to say this is a pillar of
why this food is good why it's odd it's
[__] hard but you said that that's a
pillar of why it's bad no so then why
can't I just I said that that's a bad
argument that's what I said you said
that you can't walk with the burrito you
can't walk and eat a burrito you it'll
get stuff all over you all right yeah I
do think that I do think that it's I
think you're making it so you're making
a face that it's not good so when I make
the case that it is no no but you see
you were really hinging on for a minute
that you can walk and eat this thing and
it's not a mess and I said no it is a
mess I don't agree with you I don't know
if I said it's not a mess I just said
then I made fun of the fact that you
walk and eat and I have a rule that I
don't walk and eat okay that's all
that's all I I think burritos all around
are they're they're purchased more
they're thought about more they're
craved more they're eating more they're
more portable they're more more
versatile I think that the average
burrito just it's not statistics you
have no information about it's not a
curveball if a burrito is made from one
of those five things that's its main
they make pork beef steak vegetable
chicken burritos not one of them's like
you can do that if you want but those
are actual options nobody's making a
chicken vegetable lasagna is a thing
that's beef and pork lasagnas are a
thing and a chicken might have been a
stretch but I don't think it is but you
know I I promise you if you looked it up
you'll find it Well the fans are chiming
in that cell also has um breakfast
burrito
I didn't even go there I didn't even go
there
I love a breakfast burrito I love a
breakfast burrito but I didn't liken it
to the Mexican Fair
so but in concept it is a burrito and I
didn't even go there all right that's
fine we that and that is in past
arguments that would have counted as a
unfair whatever so it's not that bad
that we didn't go there I I love a
breakfast burrito I'm not saying I'm not
saying breakfast burrito you get the
whole meal I'm sure a bite I'm saying
though and then you can walk with it I
see people walking with breakfast
burriters all the time you know
breakfast burritos not a burrito no it's
delicious a breakfast lasagna
a breakfast burrito's not the breakfast
burrito is not a burrito unless you're
talking about a Mexican breakfast
burrito meaning eggs beans jalapenos
chorizo okay a lot of people think a
breakfast burrito is eggs hash browns
and bacon like come on then anything's a
burrito at that point I love a ham and
cheese burrito put anything lasagna as
long as you bake it in the lasagna pot
I'm saying I don't think it's a crime we
didn't get the breakfast burritos as in
past arguments that would have counted
as outside we're talking traditional
versus traditional all right uh yeah
other fans are writing in that uh you
only eat lasagna when someone you love
dies
an event it's an event food you said it
yourself and you only eat and you only
eat burritos when you're shit-faced
let's be fair or terribly hungover and
then a lot of sorry Mexican culture
hello a lot of people are saying that
the beans in a burrito makes them [__]
and there's a lot of okay so it's good
to keep some regular nice all right
sorry Mexican culture
I don't know somebody said that uh doing
what you're doing lasagna's marital sex
it gets better the longer you go and
that exactly burritos are one night
stands where you just end you leave in a
mess of sauce There is that's burritos
are a lot of the time a drunken
it you know it's like let's go late
night and get burritos do it I'm
hungover let's get burritos right now
you know what like a lasagna is like
let's go sit at the restaurant oh they
have a great lasagna let's open some
wine let's enjoy later that night after
the lasagna after the wine after the bar
hop all right burrito time let's go
that's not that bad so listen to me
though you said it yourself what do you
have more in here burrito lasagna if you
love lasagna why don't you have lasagna
more because it's not as excessive but
you can do anything you want you just
tried to make McDonald's at home now you
can you can I never man I've never I've
never made a burrito at home ever ever
ever great so that means you're buying
burritos the same way you buy lasagna
but ciao I don't go as frequently to a
sit-down Italian red sauce restaurant
and what do you mean why if you love
lasagna that much it's not that hard to
go into your local restaurant and order
it a lot
I mean Pizzeria I sell it it's not like
you have to go to a [__] you don't
have to go to like uh ready here's what
I mean by more I eat lasagna twice a
year I eat burritos three times a year
why because there's one or two extra
days in a year where I go and get a
burrito because it's across the street
and I can get it in seven two to three
sounds convenient for your argument I
would tend to say that most people have
numbers way higher we're not talking
most people the US burritos six to ten
times a year in lasagna but you ask me
you didn't ask me you eat okay so you'll
design it twice three times I eat
Mexican food all the time I am telling
you something I almost never get a
burrito I get tacos I get nachos I get
enchiladas I don't think burritos are
the way to go for all of the reasons
that I've stated today I rarely get a
burrito I don't know why you don't
believe me but you don't believe me I
didn't say that I just said it was
convenient that you only got it one more
time a year than the lasagna okay I get
burritos four times I get lasagna twice
my point is is like you're saying it as
if Joe you're going to the Mexican
restaurant to get burritos weekly and
you're going to the Italian sit-down
restaurant once also by the way it just
because I like lasagna better than
burritos doesn't mean every time I go to
a sit-down red sauce restaurant I get
lasagna of course but you're telling me
that you love it so wouldn't you seek it
out more than twice every 365 days if
you loved it I what is your argument
makes no sense what the hell are you
talking about you tell me how much you
love it and you tell me you have once
every six months if you love it that
much wouldn't you have it more than
twice a year I love a lot of Italian
dishes did I once say this was my
favorite Italian Dish did I once say
that this is the question I just said no
no but but did I did I ever say any of
that I'm just asking my job here today
we love lasagna my job here today was to
defend lasagna a food that I very much
love okay but doesn't mean it's my
favorite of the Italian dishes it
doesn't mean I shake it out all the time
I just I like it better than burritos I
just said if you love it that much
wouldn't you seek it out more than two
times a year sure yes but you don't okay
sometimes I have it three times a year
so now he has it three times I don't
know my point is is is is is you just
went up 50 it's not an accessible food
this is my point that that's not a
strike against it in my opinion I could
say that I have Utz potato chips more
than any food ever on planet Earth
because we carry them a lot at the bar
and I eat them you know in Pat I'm at
the bar give me some chips really quick
I'm hungry whatever and and I love us
potato chips God bless UPS but it
doesn't mean that I think that they're
better than burritos or lasagna
it's accessibility that that that that
that that that that to me doesn't weigh
into the argument that's my opinion okay
other people running in even frozen
burritos are better than frozen lasagna
I would agree that is [__] and I
wish we would have gotten the frozen
burritos because frozen burritos as a
touring comic of 23 years who at times
is forced to eat out of that goddamn
Lobby gift shop freezer when you get
back because you forgot to get food Amy
those [__] things suck every time
frozen burritos and you put it in that
that Lobby microwave they suck that's
terrible it depends on which brand
you're getting because there are some
decent ones all right I'll believe it
when I see it but every time I get those
I'm like this tastes like beans and it
has shreds of something in it that's
supposed to be beef we're not really
talking for everything yes all right
let's we got it we gotta we gotta wrap
this up let's somebody else also wrote
is are Twinkies a burrito asking for a
friend that's a that's funny I would
give that to give that the win that's a
that's a funny tweet all right yeah why
don't I get that I don't understand that
you know what I don't get it either now
that you say are you guys ready for the
winner all right drum roll please this
is the what do we call this segment
humblebox Humble Pie what is happening
to you I haven't said it in a while I
blanked for one second yeah I thought to
say it sounds like it feels like you're
a little big for your britches you
forget where you came from all right all
right Humble Pie uh you still do
percentages yeah God bless you okay I'm
gonna lose I know I'm gonna lose but
what the [__] are you saying now I I
think I'm gonna lose then why did you
take lasagna versus burrito because I
like it better what do you mean why you
pick foods that are gonna that you think
I tell you this every week I never pick
because I think it's gonna win the
battle I pick it because I like it or I
don't like it that's it I get that and
sometimes we do the same thing I'm like
I'll do it because I love it but no I
like lasagna better I think it was a
good battle I believed in everything I
said that's how I battle but but you
think lasagna is better than why don't
you think it's gonna win because in
given the comments pimp is red it sounds
like it's leaning towards burrito yeah
but you didn't think you were gonna lose
before you started did you no I thought
I was going to win by a landslide all
right so that's what I'm saying yeah
that's what I'm saying yeah so you do
you did think you would have had a
chance to win of course but at the
beginning of the if I even if I
if I would have still taken lasagna for
sure but I just want to know that going
into it you thought you had a chance to
win I thought I had a big chance
he read four comments Joe well he's also
nodding his head when I say it's good so
last place of 43 is lasagna
43-57 closer than I thought how many
people should I thought uh
ten thousand ten thousand votes that's
pretty close fifty Seven to forty three
I I just think that
I feel like Mexican food as a cuisine in
and of itself Mexican food is more
Universal
at least here in the United States then
quote unquote Italian food uh that of
that level not pizza but like I think
that I think that the advantage is
Mexican food it's an event food versus
common food well but also no no I'm
saying something to an attribute to the
Mexican why Mexican food to me
is more
accessible or or or what people think is
Mexican food is more accessible I think
you will go to parts of this country
where Italian food is just not even an
option unless it's Olive Garden and a
lot of people even when that's the only
thing on the channel shout out to Olive
Garden we'll we'll scoff at it and go no
it's a big chain I don't want to go
Mexican food I feel like
because of the Tex-Mex variation they're
sneaking in through Chili's you know
what I mean they're just Taco Bell
they're not sneaking in that's the
identity of the restaurant but I'm
saying you know Taco Bell is the
identity by the way no offense I didn't
mean to say that Mexicans are sneaking
into anything
all right all right listen that's the
battle I still love you baby love you
too taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight